One of the most basic features of being a
boy, so well-entrenched that we forget to
notice its strangeness, is that after a certain
point, mothers become embarrassing and need
to be surrendered and denied, not just mothers,
but all that mothers tend to stand for in
a boy’s life: tenderness, vulnerability
and need. To become a man is to grow into
the creature who says ‘not now’ to his
mother – and doesn’t look back as he walks
towards his friends in the school yard. Mothers
become so-called embarrassing, because they
know all the areas in which one is not perhaps
quite the man one claims to be to the world.
Mothers have the map to the forbidden aspects
of one’s personality: they know where one
is afraid, in need of reassurance, playful
and easily moved by small and delicate things.
The mother stands, in the symbolic imagination,
as the guardian of the denied male self, of
all that was renounced on the path to that
dishonest brittle state we term masculine
adulthood. The denial of the mother is at
the root of what makes so much of adult society
heartless. We refuse to nurture one another
because we have refused to face up to the
way we were once nurtured; we behave like
people who are doing their very best to forget
their own less robust and more dependent selves.
In the summer of 1978, the French literary critic Roland Barthes
wrote a fascinating letter to his good friend,
the novelist Philippe Sollers. He told Sollers
that he’d been spending the month of August
re-reading Proust and that he had drawn from
the experience the courage no longer to refer
to his mother as ‘my mother’ but rather
to call her publicly ‘maman.’ He was at
this point 63 years old. The passage needs
to be unpacked. The French language is particularly
and instructively clear about mothers. There
are two ways to refer to this figure in French:
Mère = Mother Maman = a far cosier word,
more dignified than Mummy, but more intimate
and less off-hand than Mum, still redolent
of childhood dependence and care. ‘Mum’
is someone you occasionally send a card to;
‘maman’ is someone whose caresses you
miss. One of the many remarkable things about
Marcel Proust, the greatest writer that France
has ever produced, is that throughout his
novel, In Search of Lost Time, he refers constantly
to his mother as ‘Maman’. He does not,
as all serious French writers had done hitherto,
call her ‘ma mère’; he deliberately and
with calculated intent sticks to the far more
vulnerable ‘maman’, insisting thereby
on acknowledging the simultaneous existence
in his own mind of adult and child selves.
He performs a major rehabilitation, sketching
a new ideal of masculinity that is properly
in dialogue with childhood need. What is so
revealing is that Barthes speaks of stumbling,
in late middle age, on what he calls the courage
to refer to his own mother as ‘maman’.
He admits that it takes bravery to be open
to his boyhood self. He has to lean on the
prestige of another writer to take an apparently
insignificant but deeply symbolic and daunting
step: that of daring, as a grown-up man, to
make a public declaration of his previously-denied
longings for his mother. Or, to put it another
way, Barthes is learning that real men do
not shun their mothers; that grown-up men
can be mummy’s boys. He is, along the way,
giving all men encouragement to travel with
greater ease between the masculine and the
feminine sides of their nature, and those
of the adult and the child, rather than deny
and split, partition and then stamp on the
denied parts. We become real men when we know
how publicly to proclaim, with pride and tenderness, that we are mummy’s boys.
Thank you for watching, liking and subscribing. If you want more why not visit us in person and attend a class or take a look at our shop at the link on your screen now.